uh Matt re yes what do you guys think
about him Matt re has had an
unbelievable rise to Super startom in
the standup community
and I I saw his [__] pop up on YouTube
which which I think he must use YouTube
in a really unique YouTube and Tik Tok
Tik Tok is where he like really blew
blew quick but like unbelievable never
seen anything like it and I think
sometimes what happens is when you have
a super fast rise we were talking with
some patreon a bit but like you don't
have
your your fans don't have the time to
like really like invest and understand
you for who you are so anything that
kind of goes against their perception of
you because again they don't really know
who you are just yet they're quick to
react to and be like hey this isn't the
version of you that I thought you were
whereas like your fans fans that have
been listening to you for what the last
10 years you've been doing content you
could say pretty much any [__] up
thing and they'll be like I know who a
is I've been listening to act 8 hours a
week so I think what happens with with
Matt is he's in a situation where
there's so many people watching him that
don't really know him and then it's very
easy to get a convoluted idea of who he
is and there's a lot of people that I'm
sure are looking at him and
going [__] that guy for being so famous
remember when you get really successful
people want to tear you down that's just
human instinct I also knew him from
wilding out and he's he was a sweet he's
a kid I mean to me he's 27 now but he's
oh he's a sweet he's like a a nice
person he's I saw him do a few interiew
his Crow is great it was kind of
hilarious because I saw him with um my
man um dve poror from barol and he was
like pretty much explaining he's like yo
in a
sense he said something that I've heard
in rap before from like dve and a few
other people though like he felt like
maybe his perceived attractiveness hurts
his
comedy and that was like a whole
conversation I was like you know dve
once said that and people laughing about
it be like [__] you just can't
rap my [__] like what do you think you
look too good to rap like you know what
I mean but you know he made a like I was
listening to to his ideas about it
compelling thing it was like Hey listen
when you're a comedian you know usually
it's your words that is like you know
making people enamored about what the
[__] they're into it with you and he was
just like yo he would have these shows
where a woman would just show up just to
be like yo he looks amazing your skill
always has to exceed whatever else you
bring so Tom Brady is the most handsome
dude but he's nice and he's nicer than
he is handsome as long as you're nicer
than you are whatever else you're nicer
than you are tall you're nicer than you
are fat you're nicer than you are skinny
you're nicer are shredded nobody says a
single [__] thing Tom Brady is the
nicest quarterback that's ever existed
so nobody even talks about how he's
good-looking it's not until he's like
retired that people are like damn that
[__]
handsome because before that it was like
that [__] is nice so I think
that you could make the argument that
that's being used against him but he's
just got to make sure that he's putting
everything he possibly can into being
nice at comedy and if people know you
for being nice they don't being
attractive is awesome too but you just
got to be nice if there's a gap between
how good you are and how something else
you are people always be resentful of
that from the comedy community and I
don't know if he was alluding to that
maybe lightly is there possible
resentment on his come up because some
but but here's the problem Comics are
haters but they don't realize that like
Matt so the the example that that that
we've given before is like Russell
Peters you know Russell Peters a
comedian Indian comedian absolutely
hilarious he probably
exposed most of the world to standup and
I genuinely mean that by numbers most of
the world to stand up so that's Russell
right there hilarious yeah yeah he
exposed most of the world to stand up
like by number he probably shared
standup with more people than any other
human in
history you have to be grateful for
Russell because so many other people
myself akos are eating because he
exposed
billions of people to stand up and those
people also want other stand-ups so when
I see stand-ups hating on Matt I'm like
bro bro bro bro he got all these girls
who might have never listened to standup
to start listening to standup now
they're listening to you the same thing
like when we started putting out
stand-up Clips we were exposing whole
other audiences on YouTube to standup
that might have never listened to it now
they're listening to it don't be
resentful of the success understand that
now there's way more market share for
you to tap into
so the the resentment is like
shortsighted bitter it's hate you're
kind of smiling oh no I was like oh but
it's like is think he cute he is
cute got my point is like my point is
like you're GNA eat off of this you
think he's cute man I ain't going to lie
I heard that [__] talking about himself
looking good I'm like y this [__] is
tweaking man this ugly [__] I I
I I don't get it you don't like white
guys I don't you don't like white women
or white girls know how I don't know
what metric men who's the hottest dude
to you nobody me but there's nobody
better looking than you you don't think
anybody looks better than you I don't
look at objectively speaking you can't
say another guy as good guy act you're
being ridiculous right now yo [__]
don't look good to me not a single dude
is handsome not one [__] look we're not
saying look good to you we're saying
like you can see how women find him
attractive bro put it that way put it
that way bro that's like saying yo could
I put on my gay lens and figure out who
saly Santana not top five that's the
most gay like like saly look crazy okay
okay are there guys that are
ugly I think all guys are ugly so
there's not one guy that's uglier than
another so you're
ugly no no I ain't ugly I think all y
I'm going be honest with you think all y
ugly the same you think you're hot you
think you're sexy we're all ugly the
same I think like if I seen a girl and
and they pick between y'all like I would
be so confused use I'm like if they were
like oh no I find whoever hotter I'm
like like how but you just brought up
Dave East for example so do you think
Dave we've been laughing at that
[__] like no you just can't rap
like that but but but but but you did
bring him up as someone who presented as
good-looking yeah and you think you're
better looking than Dave East or equal
or what no I think he's an ugly
[__] act you don't have to do this you
don't have to you don't have to do this
[__] you don't have to like it's
okay no no's going to check your I
actually like Dave East making insecure
about this no one's going to check your
sexuality think he's ugly [__] man like
looking dude I think Chris Brown look
ugly I think Usher look ugly I think
Barack Obama look ugly I think Donald
Trum I think all these [__] look ugly
are yall attracted to these [__]
there's a difference between attraction
and then acknowledging the Symmetry in
someone's face some people are more
symmetrical than others and they live up
to you not talking about symmetry bro
you talking about attracting us man
who's okay is Dave East
symmetrical he's symmetrically ugly
bro
Li right there man who you trying to
prove trying hard to Pro and I don't
know
who if you have a son one day do do you
think your son would be handsome if you
look like
me I'm the only person I look at I'm
going be honest like if you find any if
you a man and you find any other man you
brother you have two brothers yeah are
they are they they don't really look
like me so they is one of them better
looking than the other nah they both
ugly ug dad wa you can't Bray me a dad
no I look like my dad like like oh say
your dad's a goodlooking ass [__] no I
a say goodl looking but like he all
though that's progress that's progress
progress progress
prog so maybe your dad could have catch
it why y got this picture with Matt R
without the shirt my [__] why does it
matter look good yo hold on I see what
he talking about he trying to tell jokes
y looking at his apps I'm just saying I
I jokes like that yo he got like a BBL
belly button man you know the BBL belly
button look like a black hole the
stretch [__] it's not stretch we know
the BBL belly button it's not what's the
BBL belly button yo why you looking at
his belly button bro yeah I know he was
you know what I'm saying I didn't even
know he had a belly butt
was hold on okay his belly button you
you're saying his I [__] with m r though
he's a funny person yo can one thing can
I say one thing his you're saying his
belly button is less attractive than
other male belly button I a never I'm
just saying you said yo one thing I'm
going to say about man R like when I was
first watching him right no no when I
was first watching him he made you I
remember I was just like yo I don't get
how funny he is because I'm like yo I
feel like he was like a dude just trying
to impress girls I'm going to be honest
with you got it um then I was just like
yo this guy is [__] hilar he's quick
and
winning quick yeah and I think that's
what he uploads to YouTube and yeah like
you know um I think he's pretty good
yeah top tier crowd work I think but
back to finding uh or not finding would
you [__] him no but understand you think
guy's goodl looking without [__] him
yeah yeah I don't know if you think I
think you think like okay okay when when
you see male models right not model like
walking the one Runway or like in an ad
for Gucci or an ad for Dior when you see
the models do you think that the casting
agents for those models are just
pointing at any guy and putting them
there or do you think there are certain
things they're looking for I you know I
do think that I think they're looking
for probably physique but facially and
you're more of a body
guy like that body I like I understand
that hold on I would say they're looking
for physique to see which which which
guy the clothes fits good on who the
[__] is this [__] that's that [__] on
steroid do you think these guys are the
same level of
attractive like those two guys left and
right same level attractiveness or or
ugliness I guess oh ugly yeah a going
lie I'll be if my [__] [__] either
one of these nigas I'll be mad just the
same well of course you'd be mad yeah
wait so you think you're better looking
than Thor no if you had to get just just
just just if a chick pick pick who Thor
that's one of right
yeah I a [__] with that if a [__] Pi
him over me man I I with that
[__] Legend wa you're a legend you're a
legend think you look good a you're a
legend yes he looks incredible though
okay listen Thor right
that okay
and yeah long hair yeah short hair is
like yeah then there's that dude no this
is a good this is a good okay now get
out of body cuz the body's distracting
just go closer to the face right right
now do do you
think this guy is in any way better
looking
than the other guy the there you're just
so confused right now you're like
perplexed bro I ain't going to lie me
y'all play like gay games bro I think
both these ugly ass [__] is the
same honest Theory can an honest the I
think you're I think you're afraid that
if you admit a guy is good looking
[__] you might be gay gay y ask G if you
ask a perent question like who do I
think is in better shape of course I
could tell not better shape we not
saying who like who do you want to get n
on attractive yeah like BR I'm going be
honest with you if you think anyone of
these attractive you gay no no no no no
we didn't say they're attractive we
who's more who's more ugly ha yeah
they're all ugly more ugly they're all
ugly who's more ugly they're all ugly
who's more ugly they both
equal that's gay that's bad gay they're
all ugly they're all ugly who's more
ugly who's more ugly yo yo you answer
the question correct you get 100 million
who's more ugly if you just answer it
correct by societal standards 25 million
by societal stand and you just got to
guess it it's not act it's not act it's
just by societal standards who's more
ugly between for saying that not can say
the truth they both ugly as
[__] I Fu gu man I knew he's going to
[__] do that you don't got to do it's
weird it's weird how much you're
overcompensating you think you think
women could be better looking and uglier
you said what you think women can be
better looking than other women yeah
because I have an attraction to women so
like I I could tell you wait wait hold
me me if I'm judging who's more who's
uglier or whatever it's based on who I'm
attracted to so put like this I might
think a girl is more attractive you
might think not because you know it's my
attraction yeah so if I'm attracted to
her for whatever reason but you're not I
think she's more pretty remove
attraction remove attraction I don't
think looks are are objective at all
okay how about this oh here we go so by
do you yeah yes okay I don't okay okay
that's fair that's fair that's fair
that's fair that's fair now what you're
basically making the argument is if the
closer to what your aesthetic is the
closer to what a girl that is attractive
for you looks like whoever gets closer
to that they're more attractive is that
fair enough yes so if there is a man
that is closer to your style you find
more
[__] say you think I got a style of
[__] that's crazy but that's that
sound crazy I'm just saying but that's
interesting to say beauty is just not
objective at all it's completely
subjective male or female no 100% that's
interesting to me I I do think
like last fres F was ask me to rate Chas
I'm like yo I really think this is
completely subjective they were trying
to actually trying so like this Shorty
for example like is she is she
attractive in your eye um is she like a
she like a eight [__] but like she has a
dick so you think that she's hey can you
scroll down can you scroll down
a dick she was you read what that says
you B she was born a dick so like that's
what can you just read what it says can
you just read what it says what this guy
doing I'm just saying she was born
guying she was she was can we just
acknowledge that that girl is fine as
[__] that's what I'm saying like that's
what I'm saying can you read what it
says just for the people for who people
what you read what the headline
says Chris Hemsworth [__] some bad
[__] oh that's a bad [__]
a girl born with a dick is yall trolling
now trolling now y trolling now y
trolling now
eight it with a dick can we acknowledge
she's kind of hot though BR here here's
my point here's my point if you fun if
if you could acknowledge that a male
looks attractive I'm not knocking I'm
not calling you gay to me I could
only visually see what would be in the
realm of attrac this to me and then
judge off like for example I have a type
of girl like like what y'all think is a
10 I probably don't think it's a 10 so
who's who's really going to be right
what you think is a
10 um BBL Caesar
beard now what's your 10 what's your 10
tell us exactly what your ten Alex check
your mic it's going to be a girl with a
natural body that's number one if you
have any fake Parts you can be attend to
me not no way no how
that I respect that right um me it might
be a a Latino or mixed girl um just say
a name no I'm describe her because say a
celebrity like just [__] 10 like what
the [__] just say an EAS like simp I a
think none of these [__] 10 like
listen we're all humans bro we all got
flaws bro like this sound like some no
one in the world who's a 10 in your [__]
no bro bro bro 10 we don't we throw
around that like a like the word goat
like everybody's a 10 it's a bunch of 10
who you think is 10 uh Beyonce's a 10
JLo's a 10 beon is a straight eight my
[__] like I so you Beyonce and this
dude are the same to you yo you [__]
B boy just GI dude as I'm just
saying Google anything look at Y young
young Sophia my [__] this picture like
was taking in the 70s dog it was she's
Sophia marara she's 70 years old
beautiful beautiful play Ruby Rose like
eight and a half to me man like you know
what I mean eight and a half not eight
and a half eight and a half Ruby
Rose you know who Ruby Ruby Rose is she
had a [__] spent
$100,000 we all have the explore page
that was I mean well but it's cat well
it was good marketing she fantastic
marketing but that's fantastic surgery I
like how you gave the trans dude at ate
though that's progress okay who is the
hottest is going to be like yo you know
what who's the hottest who's the hottest
who's the
hottest in the entertainment realm right
now
Shenia bring it up okay she she's a
Jamaican singer how you spell that s h e
n yeah right there what about shy from
uh um South Africa is a beautiful Tyler
yeah Tyler what about Tyler she's
beautiful n and she like 18 man like I
i't know no didy [__] I'm I'm a grown
man so [__] got to be at least like you
just gave a trainy a eight but she was
grown [__] y was I just pull anything
but as a
woman as a woman she probably like a
year and a half old that's I'm be y you
just gave one old [__] eight Yoo yo yo
yo yo the Tyler person she look too
young bro I'm going to be honest with
you but like like if you sure liking
like play this I would even rate
if you like R you a pedophile I actually
like
that I used to feel that way Ariana
Grande like I feel like that about her
too real talk now I know you good you
know some Diddy [__] no because here's
the thing it's like if she looks
underage if she looks like a boy man
like it don't matter if she's 23 if she
looks 14 yes I respect that because
Tyler I feel the same I was trying to
yeah it's like you like I trying to
catch you and you got me well how old is
she 21 yeah I don't care about nothing
about that
man she got to eat some meat man so you
like a little bit more thickness no I I
like people who look like like adults
adults you feel me yeah that's a good
standard you know white people they be
on some old type of [__] you know what I
mean wife I like it's white people that
y you realize the AG of consent in most
of these states is like 16 and who
invented that white people y now what's
the age of consent in non-white
countries do you think it's older or
younger n it's make is like 21 man you
can't [__] nobody talk man let's go look
at the
a go look at the aent look at thei don't
work the Wii work let's at the asan cons
white country this ain't Australian
austral white people [__] the oldest
[__] bro n n white people [__] the
oldest [__] 16 and you get daggered
at 16 where's that the age of consent
Jamaica is 16 years
old that's Jamaica Queens
[__] that's not help that's not
helping that's not helping that's not
helping that's not helping right now all
right but for real though Queens we you
don't find no guy attractive wait wa do
youall really find men attractive like
on some real [__] I'm not even [__]
with you're not sex hold yo when I look
at y' it's not like I'm like oh yeah the
wor it's just that like it doesn't like
I can't distinguish what would be more
like like if you ask I'm not wearing my
best outfit like this guy he's trying to
he trying to get like he has pretty eyes
can you acknowledge that no hold on
what you're going too hard to not be
said you couldn't even look me in the
eyes when I when you said that he not
have pretty eyes he won't even look me
in the eyes too afraid you got yo you
curl your eyelashes that's crazy you do
curl your eyelashes mad for
that eyelashes are
like your eyelashes are
like what I'm saying bro you don't if
having if having this discussion you're
like y could I acknowledge who's in
better shape who's taller got fake
eyelash got curly ass eyelashes my [__]
I ain't going to lie man yall the only
dudes mentioning man y'all want some
such say like I I'm be honest used to be
told my eyelashes was kind of CRA but
yours your eyelashes are
crazy they're like they're like this
they're like swooped up you before you
come to a podcast you take that little
metal thing and you go
like did you crimp your eyelashes what
stop acting like you your eyelashes bro
it's okay it's okay it's good now hey he
don't he don't do it he don't do it I go
lot learning from that
right look at this guy
man but look at how often you get this
[__] shaped up right here once a week
look at that guy look look at that
guy this is the sexiest man alive 2022
that's the sexiest guy alive People
magazine would you [__] him be honest
nah it's not a sexual thing for you [__]
him is so funny okay it's not a sexual
thing just it's not sexual it's just
you're just like looking at them
okay can't ask eyes cuz I I would really
ask you like why do you think this guy's
attract nah he paid for it he paid for
it paid for what he paid for that slot
this year I don't think you don't think
he attracted I don't think he offended
yo that's a good looking guy day back in
the day what was he this man been acting
40 years he's like dream yeah you would
know he's McDreamy back in the day like
10 years ago but he do
what about what about uh uh Bedford
what's his name Tyson Bedford Tyson
Beckford be some
o I always thought the [__] was gay
Real Talk being gay or being straight
doesn't change whether course if you're
gay you elim more than you're eliminated
from
what bro being hot hot we talk like we
talking about if somebody look at trct
we talk could you get listen play the
way our men talk yo yo the way our men
talk play this this compliment is how
black man give compliment like yo yo
that [__] get [__] so if you not
getting [__] like what you you think
he gets [__] right there get [__] I
ain't going to hold you but like when
you look at his face who you think get
[__] huh yeah who you think is
[__] not sa Santana no but who do you
think gets who do you think gets [__]
[__]
Al you cute though I'm married pause
that's not flirt you said it you're the
one that said it no that's not flirt
it's just like actually no actually I
think you
now and it's okay I resp why you think I
get [__] why do you think I get [__]
n he he didn't say you he didn't say you
no I didn't say no awful accomplishments
man oh saying my
sucess me don't do that he said he said
my got a great person said my looks and
your ACC so good but hold on right there
Tyson Tyson Beckford that's a handsome
you don't think that that's a handsome
guy he said he gets his dicks nah man
probably them [__] in the Freak off
man I you know let do you don't think
Diddy only like the best looking dudes
for the free didy said he was selecting
the biggest dicks that's crazy rum
there's been rumors about him you know
the whole time I'm hearing Diddy was
selecting [__] with the biggest dicks
I never got a
call never got a call so maybe it's
wrong maybe it's
maybe R question another Diddy question
sorry we need to talk about this cuz
we've been trying to figure out you said
everybody's afraid to talk about Diddy
explain the history of 50 and Diddy and
why 50 is not afraid to say that [__] yo
50 the goat bro he's incredible 50 is
the goat
no what we got to realize 50 is a little
bit different because I think 50 really
don't give a [__] nobody gives a [__]
less than 50 no well I'm gonna be honest
with you I think Diddy [__] up when he
dated 50's baby moms so there's a long
history it goes back to uh 50 trying to
like you know um sign mace there was
some contract stuff there's some music
stuff that's really in between 50 and
Diddy um you know a lot of like bad
blood but not really it's one of is like
you're in the industry with somebody you
don't like so you got to kind of like
Play Do the song and dance don't really
[__] with him but it is what it is and
then I believe it got to the point where
Diddy dates his baby
mama it's over after that I've always
said listen let me say this put it like
this like I don't even know who your
your girl is right but or let's say
ex-girl right or both y right if if if
that girl told me was like oh you knowed
to Mark I'm good because to me like we
beefing after that like I always say you
got to leave people's girls ex-girls
alone people go to war over that and I
think that's what 50 is doing man oh so
you think that this was from the past
it's not him trying of course I think I
think 50's been been waiting for this
moment for like 10 to 15 years I don't
know where it went wrong because they
did a collab there was a song where it
was puffy Diddy and JayZ that whole
billionaires
123 50 is not a liar though he's a
truthful dude he said y'all was cool and
everything was good and the [__]
ask me to he asked me to go shopping you
don't ask a man to go
shopping know I
mean youever ask smart like you want to
take him shopping I like I shop together
for sure no no no but but did you take
him shopping not shop together take him
shopping but buy him an outfit yeah no
no you going be like yo I couldn't
afford to like shopping is on me we're
going out that's a little weird not
really because if he dressed like a i'
be like yo a I'll take you shopping just
cuz I want to like help you like try to
level up your shot game it was like that
was flirting bro that was flirting right
there that was flirting with you was
FLIR I respect Saucy a little more he
said going knock me out he said he going
to take me shopping before he trying to
seduce at least s was I'm going knock
you out before you do it you don't
remember that's right you going [__]
saly that's what
up you [__] you and I don't hate you I'm
just BL like you but he was trying to
flirt with you right there yo you you
you take them in you take them in
shopping and you got to be in that
little gray area while they waiting in
the Chang
room turn around let me man say turn
around let me see that's where it's a
problem that's where a problem yo or you
and that be like yo hey does it fit like
uh uh now come on out here now you gay
you gay you gay come on now that's what
you going to do that's not what I'm
going to do I'm just trying to elevate
tell if can you tell if a dog can you
tell if a dog is better looking than
another dog a dog yeah can you be like
yeah can can you be like yo this pit is
better what type of Bal [__] you want
[__] you open that for sex just in
general literally cannot understand
objectiv is like attractive is being
objective literally like when you buy a
dog are you like oh that dog is better
looking than that dog cuter s jamaic's
dogs are different cutness nah it's a
dog a dude with no teeth hillbilly just
methhead is you think equal
attractiveness to Tom
Brady I think both of [__] is
ugly and and you think and you think if
I see a dog and I'm like oh my God that
dog is so cute why he was crying bro
understand tears I'm hon I'm like
genuinely confused like like for for
example I got a rotweiler yeah like this
never crossed my mind like hey another
dog is like bro you [__] dogs no no no
so you never thought a dog is cute you
never been like oh my God a dog is so
cute no no I've thought dogs are
adorable but I've never be like I've
never compared cut okay what man is more
adorable than another man now nigga's
not adorable to
me wait what do you have to prove like
no no you're right right I love how
committed you are this you think men are
adorable no but they you're [__] gay
this guy's [__]
G you find men adorable question you're
walking up to Mango Gucci guci guci let
me ask question some let me ask question
so if if someone asks you a question
who's more attractive me or him you
could have an answer yeah Mark not
even ass thank you thank you that that
was
he didn't have to say that part he have
to say the other part he the
last like yo my boy said that like he
had a boner n that's crazy that's CRA
did you a boner yo that dude said yo
that dude said like he had a boulder no
but def definiely he is way more
attracted than you
are
nooner way more like way more every girl
to him before come to
you
his they all walking up to him before
they walk up to you every single every
sing everybody walking up to him yo I
think he feel like d
dick no no I think he's on it I think
he's on it on that I think he's on on
that one because but do you have a boner
when you said that Bon go work off your
bonus
honey
Rhino you
caniz craziest thing is this is the most
animated
se he
the he's F you ask me if you ask me
anybody any girl and me would [__] him
first because it's such a definitive ass
question the most clearcut question
ever craziest
part the craziest part is like Marcus
sizing him up like does he even know I
don't even [__] with black d that is
true dude I know he don't
I I shut that down I shut that down God
I did shut that down earlier play we
love you we appreciate you this DJ this
is sexual tension got to this out we
going to go [__] on the patreon version
they're going to
be you part of the Freak
off part of the Freak off you